[Music]
deep in the heart of the nevada desert
is las vegas
america's ultimate sin city
each year 40 million people come to this
adult fantasy land to gamble and party
this pleasure seekers oasis fuels a
massive demand for illegal drugs what
drug can you use to keep going cocaine
that's what keeps las vegas running
people think anything goes
in the shadow of the strip there is a
fierce battleground among the dealers
fighting for a share of the vegas drug
trade
it's our territory
you know not to step on our toes
i will kill you i will definitely knock
you off
the mob built vegas i run this city on
the main guy on the choice of the earth
everything now the mexican cartels have
taken over
the drugs busy is good
this film takes you inside the world of
the gangs
the dealers
the prostitutes
and the cops this is rampant all over
the vegas valley it's an epidemic that
all make up the global 350 billion
dollar a year industry that is
drugs inc
[Music]
for tourists las vegas is the strip
four miles of mega casinos and themed
resort hotels that promised the ultimate
escape to hedonists who flock here from
all over the world
[Music]
just five miles away lies a hidden part
of vegas that no one wants seen
several blocks of cheap faded run down
motels and the people staying here
aren't from out of town
there are people who came to vegas
chasing a dream
and for most of them that dream has now
turned sour
one of those people is steve
a vietnam vet
he's been living in vegas on and off for
the past 25 years
me i just do crack
i just relax and enjoy myself watch some
tv go to bed it's like the same thing
every day it's a routine
just celebrated my birthday the other
day
64 now over the hill
wait till you get to my age
it was three years ago when this
grandfather facing unemployment turned
to crack cocaine
you sort of get a rush
at first
and relaxes your body
you don't feel uh pressure
stress it takes away my
my troubles and worries
i smoke a couple times in the evening
i buy like a 50
and smoke that but man when you get
stuffed it's no good i've had people
sell me medicine
that's nasty
so i deal with just a couple of people
that i know got good stuff
i'm gonna take one more hit and then
we'll put this stuff away i'll save up
for later
[Music]
when you do your first hit all the rest
of the hits are pretty much the same
so you're just chasing the dragon
got a nice high up there that was nice
oh
be back a little bit buddy okay
steve pays for his room out of his
military pension
but that's not enough to cover his 50 a
day crack habit
so most days after getting high
steve heads off to fremont street in
downtown and like so many in vegas
he's out there on the hustle care to
help out a bit sir
scared to help out a vet
i just go down there and people come up
and help me out
a lot of people like to help veterans
out i appreciate it god be with you
would you care to help out a veteran
some people got good hearts they like
helping people that are from the war era
especially vietnam because they know we
had it rough over there
you have a great day
when your next jackpot
be making money
four hours i can make a hundred dollars
and then do some good coke
what a rush
once steve has panhandled enough money
there are plenty of places nearby where
he can go and score
like west las vegas
only a short distance from downtown and
still in the looming shadow of the strip
west las vegas is one of the city's most
drug-ridden neighborhoods
[Music]
it's a hotbed for vegas's crack cocaine
industry
you got a certain product and people
want it is called supply and demand so
we take advantage of that
cocaine is one of the biggest things
going in vegas city never sleep lights
stay on what drug can you use to keep
going cocaine y'all saying
selling cocaine isn't how baby doe earns
the big bucks he makes crack
you're probably putting
six seven thousand in your pocket and
only spending two or three thousand
mariah
i'm gonna show you how we do this on a
manufacturing tip to make crack all baby
dough needs is an empty kitchen some
household products and a large quantity
of cocaine
this is cocaine before crack
i'll take this ounce right here 28 grams
you go right in the bag
i would take
more water
i would move this to us over here and
now let that cement cook
and not that meltdown to a gel substance
i'll just start pouring this in there
once i start pouring this in there it'll
turn into magic
the rest of baby doe's recipe is a
closely guarded secret
within 25 minutes baby doe has taken 800
worth of cocaine and turned it into
crack
see how hard that is that's some good
i can sell all that together sixteen
hundred dollars this little piece for
like
450. we getting dollars out here we
ain't playing out here
with the master class over babydoor
reminds his boys that to make the real
money you've got to think big
a person can't go buy eight ball of dope
and just cook it up you might just come
back with a gram and a half a crack
you can buy a zipper potter for 800
bucks with a half ounce of baking soda
the baking powder will make it stretch
now i made an ounce and a half a dough
you don't need four hundred dollars off
your 800. you know i'm saying that fast
you really gotta pay attention
to what's going on one thing about this
game
you can have too many chiefs you only
need one chief
and a couple of indians and i started
from the bottom all the way up now i'm
my own chief i'm not the enemy no more
even though baby doe is the boss
this doesn't mean he takes home all of
the profit if i decide to pay you a
thousand i give him a thousand him a
thousand him a thousand i pay myself a
thousand even though i got to connect
even though i am the manufacturer i want
to pay evenly we all get equal pay this
profit sharing ensures loyalty from his
gang of runners
i don't use phones don't use computers
if you want to contact me you got to
contact somebody i know
you can't call me
it's hard to find me
i'm saying if anything i'll find you
keeping a low profile isn't just about
keeping under the police radar
you got killing you got gang banging you
got hustling you have prostitution you
have robberies you have
grand larceny whatever you want to call
it you have it in vegas
baby doe may try to keep his head down
in the local neighborhood where he deals
[Music]
but for those chasing the tourist
dollars on the las vegas strip the risks
and dangers can be far greater
with the biggest threat not coming from
law enforcement but from getting robbed
by rival street dealers
if you're gonna rob me you're gonna have
to catch me out in the streets you're
gonna have to actually set me up like i
just got set up yeah i mean the other
night
i just got robbed
we do our transaction everything goes
smooth
i give him the weed he give me 3 200
as soon as i walk outside another dude
run up on me with the pistol like you
know with a gun
give me the money i know you got the
money like you know so i try to run back
into the spot when i try to turn around
and go back in dude close the door it's
a setup
deadly dollars is seething
his extensive network of drug runners
have their ears to the ground looking
for those responsible
i'm waiting on a phone call from one of
my runners because we might have already
found who this person is
the simple fact that i got enough clout
to have people go find you
you know that i'm serious
in this game when you get robbed
it's hard to decide what you do
deadly dollars is weighing up his
options
but from what i'm hearing he's a
teenager
i can't sit here you know and take
somebody's child from him he got to
learn a valuable lesson though he will
have to work for me
in the drug business situations like
this put a whole new spin on hostile
takeovers
every single dollar you make you got to
bring it to me first and then i give you
what i want to give you i treat you like
a prostitute now
until your tab is clear
you owe my business you gotta pay that
if you try it to me again i will kill
you
i would definitely knock you off
[Music]
tourists flock to vegas not just for the
gambling
but also for the girls
prostitution remains illegal but inside
the casinos and up and down the strip
working girls are impossible to avoid
and these girls know that the tourists
have money to burn
not just on sex
but also on drugs
most people know me the high class ass
out on the strip
most people they don't know where to get
the drugs at so they call me up and ask
me can i get a couple eight balls or
or can i get some pills or wear the weed
at
people that come to las vegas they want
to do powder cocaine
[Music]
they want to upper so they can stay up
for days
i would go buy an eight ball for 150
and then i'll go sell it for
350. i'm making pretty good money off of
that
brandi does more than just supply her
clients
she's developed a profitable sideline
dealing to other girls who work the
strip
most of the time when somebody would
call me for drugs it's a girl that's
already working and i would go pick it
up from some place
and then i would drop it off down to the
strip to where they are at
there's an added benefit for dealers
using working girls like brandy to push
their drugs
the drug dealers they meet people like
me the less people they meet the longer
they stay in business it's just to keep
them out of the limelight
for brandy las vegas is a prostitute's
paradise
the casinos want the drugs and the girls
to be there
without us there's no vegas
[Music]
this presents a difficult challenge for
the officers whose job it is to police
the strip
the big thing is this is a big tourist
town and this is las vegas so a lot of
people want to come down here to have a
good time and people's good times can be
from going to a club to going to club
with drugs
people get a false sense that vegas is
isn't real it's just a fun town they can
do what they want
they think they can get away with it but
uh
the reality of it is they can't
unlike some other parts of nevada
prostitution is actually illegal in
vegas
yet for detective clarkson and his squad
working girls are impossible to
avoid out here
i find it kind of odd when you see me
and then you're like oh crap there's the
police i saw the look all over your face
okay uh are you leaving you have any
idea on your screen yeah i do
tourists are coming up to them asking
them hey where can i you know score some
coke or
pills
and they're just you know we're kind of
seeing the opportunity to make a little
bit more money on the side
if i see you over here again you will go
to jail okay okay you understand that
yeah okay i suggest you move along
and go conduct your business elsewhere
uh people think anything goes they can
get frustrated especially when we're
just trying to protect them tourists
don't you know they're not at home they
don't know exactly where they can get
their narcotics when they come here they
can ask somebody if they want it now
they're going to try to get it now and
pay for whatever it is they need to pay
for
working girls aren't the only people in
town who tourists can go to to get their
drugs
[Music]
behind the facade of the strip exists a
network of discreet go-to fixers called
vip hosts
they offer party goers a chance to live
the vegas dream and feel like a
hollywood star
guaranteeing them access to the hottest
nightclubs the coolest parties and the
sexiest girls
but what they don't openly advertise is
some of the added extras they're also
willing to provide
at the right price
about 60 to 70 of people who come out
here want to do drugs i make sure i get
it for them
i have clients from 21 year old college
students all the way up to doctors
lawyers stockbrokers everybody has money
to spend when they come out here and
they spend it with me
i'll get a group of guys that'll let me
know when they're coming to town they'll
say they need some party favors and if
it's cocaine
ecstasy
marijuana lsd
whatever they need i'll go out and find
it for them and they don't have to worry
about you know finding some random
person on the strip
i take out the worry for them and i go
get the drugs for them from you know a
dealer that i'm consistent with and that
knows that you know i'm i'm not a cop
as a vip host
johnny favor makes a good profit for the
services he provides
from a business perspective if i was to
buy an eight ball of cocaine that would
be 3.5 grams of cocaine i would get it
for 200 and i would resell to my clients
for 300. i make about a couple thousand
dollars one night and you know make
another couple thousand the next night
johnny favor believes hotels turn a
blind eye to what's really fueling the
24-hour gambling culture that takes
place in their casinos
that's what keeps um las vegas running
is the drugs you know because drugs are
going to keep people gambling at the
tables it's going to keep them up
and that's good for business for not
just me but for the casinos
johnny favor is under no illusions that
by supplying drugs to his clientele he's
taking massive risks
sometimes the amount of drugs that i
pick up for some of my clients
it does have a lot of worry for me if i
were to get um stopped it's it's
considered trafficking
[Music]
across town just off the strip las vegas
police have pulled over a man and a
woman seen acting suspiciously in a
hotel parking lot
[Music]
smoke it
okay
they've already found some evidence of
drug use so detective clarkson decides
to search their car further
i got hypos all in the glove box here
all right
they're all still
sealed up yeah
with a mountain of drug paraphernalia in
her car the woman denies it's got
anything to do with her
because she had nowhere to go so i told
her i would take you know some of her
stuff to our mom's house
so
i mean
and she currently is still you know
using
what i
[Music]
for detective clarkson her story just
isn't stacking up what's your drug of
choice when you use drugs
um used to be you're not in drugs
anymore when's the last time you've used
um math like i told him about six seven
months ago practice it's been at least a
year here now can you do me a favor can
you close your eyes for me real quick
[Music]
okay listen
i'm not gonna take you to jail because
you said you've done drugs
but it's been a lot sooner than six
months hasn't it
when's the last time you've done it
don't be don't start lying to me okay i
judge a person by their honesty okay and
i know you're lying to me when's the
last time you've used
almost 24 hours almost 24 hours ago
has been since then huh looks a little
sooner than that i don't know
yesterday afternoon almost one o'clock
[Music]
what did you use
you got kids
how many kids do you have
where your kids ever
their dad's house we must like put it
you know all together and i'm not doing
it every once in a while i i don't want
to live in the same household yeah
you want to raise your kids around drugs
do you no so what do you think a smart
thing would
dog to stop right
with no drugs found on this occasion
there's very little the police can do
she just get got caught up
with some bad people at an early age
and she continues to make bad choices
what it sounds like
and uh
got caught up hanging out this guy
sounds like they do uh drugs together
and she just seems to
continue falling down that bad road
the las vegas strip
150 000 luxury hotel rooms
around 6.1 billion dollars generated in
gambling revenue each year
america's ultimate adult playground
but directly below this fantasy land
is a hidden world made up of 300 miles
of tunnels and storm drains
here in this labyrinth a secret
community of drug users make these dark
and dangerous tunnels their home
i told you i'd be right back
i did
i told you didn't i
travis is 33
and came here from south carolina 10
years ago drawn to vegas for the
gambling
down in the tunnels travis seeks solace
in a substance that can completely
transform his mood
got me a little bit of drugs
i'm loading the bowl getting ready to
smoke
i don't need it i like doing it because
it's just it makes me feel good
sometimes methamphetamine is a crude
chemical cocktail that acts as a
powerful stimulant on the body
i guess you could say i'm one of those
persons that
if it's there i'm going to want to do it
you know
just like if i have money i want to go
out and gamble
travis doesn't believe he's addicted to
meth
if you start doing drugs i'm going to
tell you
you better keep your mind straight don't
let the drug take you over because you
can do the drug and don't let the drug
do you but he admits he is addicted to
the tables
i'll take a 20 and throw it in
on one hand a blackjack
i'll take a hundred and throw it in on
one hand of blackjack
i've spent more money on gambling than
anything
his addiction to gambling costs travis's
job and apartment
and while i'm smoking i try not to think
about the rest of the world out there
until i get out there
they don't have no mind on me none
travis has been down in the tunnels for
five years
and only ventures out when he really has
to
but for other tunnel dwellers
their drug addiction means they have
little choice but to emerge
believe me some days you don't want to
do it but you know in your mind that if
you don't do it
you're not going to
be able to do your drug
joe's been addicted to heroin for the
past four years
and needs to inject himself at least six
times a day
my dope man gets
2 500 for me every month
if i quit doing drugs and still made
that money every day
i'd be in an apartment
my main reason for being afraid to leave
here
i don't want to have to go to a new city
and try to find heroin i couldn't
imagine
you know having to go a couple days sick
while i was trying to find some in
another
city
this drug right here makes you nod
you don't take short naps you know
um
while heroin leaves joe's semi-conscious
elsewhere travis's drug of choice
methamphetamine has the opposite effect
he feels it motivates him
i get to doing things then
when i smoke it throws a couple of
options up in there for me
once the meth kicks in
travis becomes a very different person
[Music]
while high he goes dumpster diving
and illegal activity scavenging through
people's trash looking for things he can
sell i hate like that
thousands of them i see these things
right here constantly
one would never imagine the stuff that
they could find in dumpsters
it's naproxen and i used to know what it
was for but it's not like a pain pill or
nothing
but you know i mean i hold on to stuff
like that
me i just go out looking for cans really
and whatever i come across
24 of these cans equals a pound last
time i took 24 pounds i walked away with
32 bucks and some change
[Music]
another way travis makes his money is by
hustling the casinos
credit hustling is like when
i walk through casinos strolling by and
if i see a machine that has like light
split up on it you know it normally
means that it has money on it
so if nobody's sitting at that machine i
would either you know play it a couple
of times cash it out go with the money
the one thing you don't want
to ever happen is somebody to come up
behind you dressed up in a security
outfit
they could either simply ask you to
leave don't come back or either take you
down to security holding
[Music]
if you're stupid enough drunk enough to
leave your money on the machine if i'm
not going to get it
the next person to come along will
it was the mob that first built the
strip back in 1946 but now it's
multinational corporations that rake in
billions from the mega casinos and
themed resorts
another type of corporation is now also
operating in vegas
they control the large-scale
distribution and trafficking of drugs
succeeded to make money this is the
business city i mean they are the
mexican cartels
las vegas it's a transit town people are
in and out of here for a number of
different reasons including jobs
and
you know one of the jobs out here is
drug running
we're coming into our first location now
one of our detectives has an informant
who can buy heroin from one of the local
drug organizations
today's police operation is called a
controlled buy
no arrests will be made its main purpose
is to gather intelligence on how the
mexican cartels operate in las vegas
they're they're mexican nationals
they're illegal immigrants
and they are here to sell drugs
mexican crews are so well organized that
ordering drugs is as easy as ordering a
pizza
the the mexican dispatch centers it's a
business working from nine to five
nine o'clock in the morning all the
runners would turn their phones on some
of the runners actually have maps in
their cars
and they just have numbers and it's it's
a city map with numbers on it
so the dispatcher will send one of his
runners to location number one i hate to
give him credit but it's a very well run
business
hello
i'm good i'm set bring him in
the informant has arrived and is parked
in a white chrysler
he's waiting for the mexican runner to
come and deliver the drugs
sergeant lotito has undercover officers
positioned across the parking lot
yeah he's rolling north
[Music]
for the police this is a tense moment
drug cartels often run counter
surveillance watching for police
operations just like this
now
eventually the runner seems confident
enough to park
here he comes chuck's out walking
towards his car the informant goes over
to meet the runner and in seconds the
deal is done i got a picture and zoomed
in it's pretty clear
the operation is far from old
now a police surveillance team will
covertly follow the runner to gather
more intel on the supply chain
meanwhile sergeant lotito needs to
establish exactly what quantity of
heroin the informant bought
we got a gram and a half here for 80
you can see how they're packaged in the
toy balloons
sometimes they're color coded for the
type of drug
a typical runner will go through
multiple ounces in a day
these runners operate on the very bottom
of the drug supply chain
there's always somebody higher it's it's
very difficult to get to the head of the
snake
it's the mexican kingpins making
millions for the cartels who the police
ultimately want to track down
i run this city on the main guy
i'm the top guy he's entrusted
everything he don't remember the one
that measures all the drugs out of the
way
make sure everybody gets paid i'm the
choice of uh everything
the drug's busy is good man because this
is the legacy when you hear me people
come to party here we bring up crystal
meth and um we bring it from mexico
that's ec
rodriguez isn't just trafficking meth
into vegas he's also bringing in huge
quantities of weed and cocaine
we bring about
three million dollars worth of money
that's the value of the drugs over here
he pays half the money up front at
wholesale prices
this goes directly to his bosses 300
miles away in mexico
then when the morning's out there
the drops on the
a stash and of course we put us inside
the wheels when you cross the border you
don't get to take the way here to las
vegas
once the drugs are trafficked across the
border the cartel uses san diego as a
distribution hub
[Music]
[Applause]
we're driving homeboy we were like three
cars
the main thing that we do we put a
cruise control
so that way we know there's gonna be
stuff for speed limit when they use cell
phone we use um on radios
we use a radio strips so that way is is
faster the driver is the one to get the
the most rich we don't use punishment so
that way gonna be like oh three cars
full of spanish people what's going on
we give white people black people you
know i mean like if something happened
wouldn't be connected if they get
stopped when we take responsibility our
responsibility to uh to get a lawyer to
build them out
as the kingpin rodriguez must be low-key
to stay under police radar
you have to change appearances
i'll drive different cars
i never stay in one house i got like
three four houses i just spent three
days in this one some time ago another
one you know me so you don't bring
attention you know me that's that's how
the real drug dealer had to be
sometimes you move to different state we
rotate every three year four years in
the middle where you don't get hot you
don't go to jail not nothing happen to
you
in the cartel it is possible to move up
the ladder
but only if you're delivering really big
bucks
the big people from the cartel started
looking at you like this guy is making
good money good morning that's how you
go you take steps you know i mean
sometime in the year i can give it to
about 10 million dollars my enemy
in a year
with so much money at stake
there are grim consequences for anyone
who dares to cross rodriguez and his
cartel
the people who work for us is people
close we know the family we know who you
are and
one of my workers niche and also
whatever
you're gonna pay for it you're gonna
take your family away
then it's over you mean she's a wrap
las vegas is one of the worst hit cities
in the recent housing crash
and criminal gangs involved in
large-scale marijuana grows are
capitalizing on this
one in ten homes was in some stage of
foreclosure last year almost five times
the national average
this means there's an abundance of empty
homes available to buy or rent
today the drug enforcement
administration is acting on intelligence
it received about a sophisticated
marijuana grow house in an upscale vegas
suburb
just like our plan is we're going to go
to the door that's going to be our
secondary
route 4 you're going to pop the gate on
the side
go around to the back
and hold with the shield at the corner
right yes we're all going to go in the
van knocking announce
nearest hospital
at spring valley if anything goes wrong
okay let's load up let's go
in the last five years
there's been a 200 increase in the
number of grow houses busted in vegas
many of them are run by ruthless asian
criminal gangs
in the past agents have found large
quantities of firearms and ammunition at
these properties
they have no idea what to expect as they
go in
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
downstairs it's a ghost house
but upstairs each room is crammed full
of marijuana plants
438 in total
the whole house has been converted into
into a grow
so there's ventilation water
basically nobody lives here
it confirms everything the intelligence
suggested
this is a large-scale commercial grow
with a street value around 1.3 million
dollars
a vehicle concern to the dea is the
potentially fatal way the criminals
behind the grow has subverted the
electrical supply
all right you see where that that false
wall is there they rewire the house so
it doesn't show up on the electrical
meter that there is hazardous would
basically cause a house to catch on fire
and if you notice how close the houses
are you're going to probably take the
whole block especially with the winds
that are in vegas
the only reason they do it is basically
to hide the electricity use of the
lights to grow the marijuana
okay upstairs loft plank cam
got high powered lights up there that
basically simulates sunlight you notice
on the house the windows are blocked out
that's basically to block
the grow lights from people out here
seeing it because it basically would be
like looking at a like a concert it
would basically light up the whole the
whole area 49
suburban area pretty nice neighborhood
but that's what they typically do they
take a house where it's not going to
stand out and then convert it into a
grow and it's not suspicious the only
thing suspicious he comes and goes once
a day and nobody actually lives there
this is rampant all over the vegas
valley with all the vacant houses i mean
like i said they have an entire squad
it's dedicated to nothing but indoor
grows in vegas because it's it's an
epidemic
with the feds leading the fight against
large-scale drug production it's up to
the las vegas metro police department to
crack down hard on the dealers
this corner apartment selling narcotics
has been detectives from the dedicated
gang unit are preparing to go on a night
patrol in some of the city's worst hot
spots for gang-related drug crime
[Music]
well this area it's uh known for its
high gang volume and narcotics activity
narcotics activity and gangs usually go
hand in hand it's usually how they fund
their products and
create havoc in their area
we have thousands and thousands of gang
members documented here you throw a rock
in this neighborhood and somebody's
usually
either has drugs or has been selling
drugs
the unit has pulled over a woman seen
acting suspiciously
this is your car this is my car what
kind of car is that it's a bmw 760. what
do you do for a living if you don't want
me to ask me i work for a child care
place i work for a group home actually
they give pages pretty good money um
[Music]
somewhat have you ever been in trouble
before yes sir what have you been in
trouble for for high-level trafficking
high-level trafficking of what cocaine
cocaine
officers of metro's las vegas police
department have pulled over a woman seen
acting suspiciously what was the details
of that if you don't mind me asking my
boyfriend my ex-boyfriend and i was in
the wrong place at the wrong time like i
am right now who's your boyfriend
i'll sit tight for a second all right
they run further checks on her and her
boyfriend who they discover as a known
gang member
she's gonna have some info man like i
said she's got priors for high level
trafficking or something like that and
uh her man has the same so they're
obviously feeling the dope game somehow
[Music]
the police now begin a thorough search
of the car
sometimes they put traps in their
vehicle there will be a special button
that they can push that uh will be under
a secret compartment underneath their
floorboards or underneath the car and
their hoods
the criminals that transport drugs very
very creative when it comes to
trying to keep it hidden from us
so far no drugs have been found
but police will arrest her anyway
because she has no insurance and a
suspended driver's license
this will buy the police valuable time
to impound her car for a closer
inspection
in some cases they can strip the car
down until it's unusable
depending on where they hide the drugs
or where the traps are
[Music]
there are more than 300 gangs hustling
drugs on the streets of las vegas
and one of them on the west side of town
is the playboy bloods
i'm a hustler you know what i'm saying
selling hard soft
weed whatever it's pretty much an
addiction you know to the fast money
your lifestyle this is this is the job
i started this game when i was like 13
dropped out of school early
i just watched hustlers you know and i
became one myself i was infatuated with
the lifestyle nice cars clothes women
noticed what i wanted to do
these gangsters are very protective of
their turf
it's our territory if you're from here
you notice our territory you know not
step on our toes
rival gangs know that there will be
deadly consequences if they stray into
blood turf
we sent some guns at him
no get him out the way
shoot at them knock them off
whatever it take
y'all ain't from the same neighborhood
we from you got to go
for the playboy bloods pushing their
product is a full-time occupation
my daily routine i get up maybe seven in
the morning
i get my drugs um i go to an area where
i sell my drugs
and um i pretty much stay there until
i'm i'm sold out pushing this
from the time i wake up to the time i go
to sleep 24 hours if i have to
for any tourists stumbling off the strip
in search of a cheaper deal on the
streets
they're in for a surprise
when they come on outside of town they
don't know the prices
so uh you can help the prices on them we
always gonna make double for one we
don't want to deal with you so we might
as well charge you
jj's been hustling for 20 years
but he's still got his sights set on
bigger things
you got kids that want to grow up to be
football stars basketball players and in
my lifestyle i want to be the man i want
to be the big man life more comfortable
at the top
next year i want to be higher than what
i am today
it's pretty much my dream
[Music]
it's 2 a.m on the streets of west las
vegas
drug runners are winding things down for
another night
this means it's a time when large
amounts of cash get moved around between
dealers and their suppliers
something the gang unit knows all too
well
routine car stops can often yield good
results
as the detective leans in he notices an
open container of alcohol
in front of my car come on
you know it's against the container in
the vehicle i'll put the bank outside
until we figure out what's going on all
right you're not under arrest but if and
when you are i'll let you know you
understand
how much money you got on your man
a couple of hundred turns out to be just
over a thousand dollars
this makes the detectives suspicious
and as they run their checks they
discover that this man has previous
convictions for violence and drug
dealing
he is also a known gang member
what kind of work you do
it's not working right now it'll work
it's a lot of money to be carrying with
you man for someone who doesn't have a
job how do you make all your money
gamble yeah sure what we gamble on today
so what did we gamble on today
we played slots or no i wanted to craft
that on texas last night i came all the
time oh okay pretty successful
yeah we got stopped as a uh
well-documented gang member he's got
narcotics priors he had a large sum of
currency on them and uh it's in smaller
denominations which is consistent with
the street level narcotics sales they
think it's one of their key skirt
arounds for them to say that they want
some money gambling in las vegas usually
when people win uh a jackpot or
something like that they'll be paid out
in large bills people that have 20s tens
and fives and stuff like that's not how
jackpots are paid out i just kind of
adds a little more suspicion to what we
think might be going on here
both the detectives on the scene and now
the k-9 unit searched the man's car
but no drugs are found
with a suspicious cash haul the police
decide to take him in to investigate
further
your money we are seizing it for this
purpose is now just due to the fact that
we believe that it's involved with
narcotic transactions due to your prior
history and support that's what's going
to happen today sir
we're going to take the money and do
some follow-up investigation on try to
time into it a little bit more and go
from there
for the officers of metro's las vegas
police department the cat and mouse game
with drug dealers suppliers and
traffickers goes on
it's a battle with no end in sight
as long as tourists flock to vegas the
demand for drugs will remain
with the vip hosts the call girls the
street dealers and the cartel bosses all
the more happy to supply them in this
high-stakes drug game
[Music]
you